welcome everyone welcome to the final
session of the workshop I first start
with the look of the final session is
computing the independence polynomial
and shares in general a little and we'll
be talking again about polynomials my
favorite topic and this is joint work
with piu Srivastava and young Vondrak so
I'm going to start with a statement of
the lll since we're sort of a mixed
audience here so I presume many of you
will know this and some of you may not
so the the lowest local lemma is a
famous tool in probabilistic
combinatorics and can be stated as
follows so if you have events II wanna
to and so on in a probability space and
you assume a certain dependency
structure on the events so so if each
event is independent of all but a small
number of other events so most d other
events and you know that each event is
not too likely
so each event occurs with probability at
most one over E times D plus 1 then the
lavash local EMA asserts that it's
possible to avoid all of the events so
the the probability of the intersection
of the complements of the events is
strictly positive and so it's kind of an
interesting phenomenon here is that it's
reviewed as a non constructive tool
right it's showing the the existence of
this point in the intersection of the
complements of the events but but the
probability of that set could be
exponentially small so if you tried just
drawing random samples to find such a
point then it could take an
exponentially long time to find it this
needle in a haystack that problem ok so
let me give an example of this so a
simple example to colorability of
hypergraph so we have a set system or a
hyper graph
and we assume that that each hyper edge
has bounded size so size at most K and
we also assume that each hyper edge
intersects not too many other hyper
edges so each hyper edge intersects at
most 1 over 2 e times 2 to the K hyper
edges and our goal is to color the nodes
of this hyper graph with two colors red
and blue and our goal is to avoid having
monochromatic edges so we want that
every hyper edge should contain both
colors red and blue ok so one thing we
could so to set up our probability space
to discuss the local EMA we're just
going to take a uniformly random
coloring so imagine independently
coloring the nodes red and blue ok so
let's see how the the LOL applies in
this in this case so for each so we need
to define some some events that we'd
like to avoid the events will will
correspond to the hyper edges being
badly colored so we say that event E I
occurs if the hyper edge AI is
monochromatic all red or all blue and
now we have a nice dependency structure
on the events because because of our
assumption that that each hyper edge
intersects a small number of other hyper
edges so because of that we obtained
that every event E I is independent of
all events EJ where those two sets do
not intersect where they don't share a
node ok and then we need to check the
parameters at the local lemma so because
we we assume that there is this
restriction on the intersections then we
know we so the D parameter on the
previous slide the the number of events
that then an event is you know dependent
on is bounded right so we get this bound
D plus 1 is at most 1 over e times 2 to
the K minus 1
now we've chosen the parameters
carefully so that if you look at the
probability of an event occurring so the
probability that an edge is badly
colored is 2 to the 1 minus K right 2 to
the minus K is the probability of each
coloring and there's two bad colorings
all red and all blue so that's the the
probability of the bad events and the
parameters are chosen so that the the
inequality we need is is satisfied and
so the hypotheses of vlll are satisfied
and that tells us that there's positive
probability that no hyper edge is
monochromatic but this probability will
typically be exponentially small and so
that's what we will need to deal with
okay so so then the question is how can
you find such a good coloring right how
can we make an algorithmic version of
the lll so there's been a long history
of work on this problem dating back to
work of Beck and then many many
improvements on this it's a it's a long
list I've probably missed many from this
list and there was a big breakthrough in
2008 this with this algorithm of Moser
and what Moser said is that he gave the
simple algorithm basically just look for
any hyper edge that's badly colored and
recolor it randomly so here we have a
blue hyper edge it's badly colored we
randomly recolor it now we find a red
with this red one that's badly colored
and then this one and we keep going and
then eventually it converges to a good
color so there theorem is that if the if
the hypotheses that we had are satisfied
then this algorithm will terminate in
expected polynomial time
okay so so now let's step back a bit and
let's let's sort of take a high-level
view of the previous algorithms for the
for the local lemma so essentially all
of them are of that same sort as the the
Moser algorithm I just described so if
we think of the space of possible
coloring so I have my cube here of
colorings then we have some feasible
region of good colorings and what the
algorithm is doing is it's randomly
generating integral points these
colorings is randomly generating
colorings until they until it lands in
the feasible set so it randomly picks
some coloring which is not good
randomly pick some other coloring and
some other coloring and eventually the
the you know the convergence guarantee
is that eventually you will find a
coloring that lands in this feasible set
ok so the first message I'd like you to
take away from this talk is that we can
do something different here we can take
a different view of the dynamics of an
algorithm for the lll so what we will do
is basically a rounding algorithm for
the lll so so what we will do is we'll
start with a feasible fractional
coloring so so throughout I'm just going
to be talking about hyper graph coloring
instead of talking about general
probability spaces so that'll be our
running example so we will start with a
fractional coloring for this hyper graph
coloring problem then what we will do is
we will perturb the coordinates we will
round each coordinates one by one two
until they're integral while maintaining
feasibility we're still in this feasible
region ok so we make the first
coordinate integral second chord
integral and then we we stop when we we
land at a vertex in the feasible region
ok so that's going to be our our
approach ok so now I need to introduce
some more notation so we talked about
the sort of the dependency structure
that the the local lemma needs so so if
we start with these with this hyper
graph coloring problem we need to define
the notion of a
see graph so we will have a vertex
corresponding to every hyper edge that
needs to be colored and the then the
edges in the dependency graph so the
indicating these events that depend on
each other those come from hyper edges
that intersect as we said before so
hyper edges intersect yield edges in the
dependency graph and we know that the
maximum degree in the dependency graph
is at most D because we have this
bounded independence property ok so let
me make one observation that we will
return to later let's observe that if I
fix a particular node in the hyper graph
so let's say this this node in the
corner here so this is a node that we're
going to color and I look at all the
hyper edges containing that node they
form a clique because of our definition
of this dependency structure right so if
I have these three sets then I have a
three click on those those vertices in
the dependency graph that make sense
okay remember that fact because we will
come back to it okay now now come here
come the polynomials so what we're going
to look at is the independence
polynomial of this dependency graph and
actually it'll be the multivariate
independence polynomial with alternating
signs so I'm going to stick in a minus
sign there so we have a we have a real
parameter or even complex as we'll see
later but we have this parameter PV for
each vertex in the dependency graph
corresponding to the hyper edges and
then we sum over all the independent
sets the product of those those
corresponding variables in the
independent set ok so back to this
feasible region in the previous picture
this purple region that we're trying to
stay within so what is this feasible
region I I said it was the region of
good colorings but then we had
fractional points inside it I didn't
tell you what the fractional points are
so here is actually how we will define
the feasible region so it's it's called
the Shiro region and it's defined using
these independence polynomials so here's
the definition
so basically the independence polynomial
at every point P prime that is major
eyes by the point P must be strictly
positive so so you can think of it as
we're avoiding zeros of the independence
polynomial in a certain strong sense so
essentially I mean there's many
equivalent definitions of it you can
also think of it as the if you think of
the dividing the space into regions
defined by the the zeros of this
independence polynomial then we're
looking at the connected component
containing the origin that's the that's
the Shiro region okay so so Shearer who
defined this stated the the following
strong form of the Lobos local lemma so
if you have these events where pi is the
probability of event E I and then you
have this dependency structure defined
by this dependency graph then as long as
this vector P of probabilities lies in
this shear region then the conclusion of
the local lemma holds you can avoid all
the events with positive probability and
it's a precise characterization in that
the statement is false for all points
outside of the the shear region
okay so so the shear region is a bit
hard to visualize so let's just think of
the univariate version so we're just
restrict to the case where all the P I
values are the same so and let's define
the minimum root so the root closest to
the origin of this independence
polynomial let's call that lambda G so
we know that the independence polynomial
it's a univariate it has no roots in
this region up to lambda G and then
after that point it can have plenty of
roots so what sure is Lama is saying is
if your probabilities are lie in this
blue region then the conclusion of the
local EMA is true and then once you're
past that region then the conclusion of
the local EMA is false and it's also
interesting to characterize or to look
at what happens restricting to degree D
graph so graphs of maximum degree D so
if we let lambda prime sub D be the
smallest value of that lambda G so the
closest root to the origin over all
graphs of maximum degree D then and then
we call that lambda prime D then then
the value of that is precisely known and
it's about 1 over e D and that 1 over e
D is no coincidence that's essentially
the same value that showed up in the
original form of the local lemma
slightly slightly better ok so now that
we know what this feasible region is
let's talk about our are rounding
approach to the local lemma and again
just just restricting the example of
hyper graph coloring so here is our
gears our algorithm it's essentially as
as simple as can be so we're starting
with this initial random coloring the
uninformative coloring where
everything's half red and half blue then
all we do is examine the
the nodes of the hypergraph one by one
and we color them either red or blue
whichever will preserve feasibility in
this set in this shara region and then
once that's done then then you just
return that coloring okay so that is our
is our local lemma algorithm and so we
need to prove two things first of all
that such a choice of coloring is always
possible that you cannot always preserve
feasibility in the Shiro region and then
second of all algorithmically how can
you make such a decision okay so first
let's start with the the existential
question okay so remember our
definitions we have our independence
polynomial and our Shura region the
first thing I'm going to do is cheat so
because we had this sort of complicated
major ization condition which really is
just adds confusion and doesn't really
add much difficulty to the proof so it
just sort of complicates the notation
and to keep things simple on the talk
I'm just going to ignore it so the crux
of the proof is really just this case
with this simpler set okay so then we
also have this definition PV is the
probability that our hyper edge a Savi
is monochromatic so now let's look at
how that can be expressed in terms of
the coloring probabilities of the
variables remember the algorithm is
perturbing those so let's let X u be the
probability that we color node u red
then this PV this probability of being
monochromatic is just the probability
that your hyper edge is all red or all
blue so we can write it this expression
in terms of the X variables
and one observation is that this is a
multi linear polynomial and X right so
the probabilities of the events being
bad is a multi linear polynomial in the
colouring probabilities of the notes
okay now remember that's observation I
asked you to remember earlier so let's
go to that so the so we said that the
hyper edges containing a particular node
you form a clique and so that means that
the vertices V for which this P V
polynomial depend on a particular X you
value the particular X you variable
those vertices of the dependency graph
form a clique all right now as Mika used
in his talk yesterday this useful facts
that independent sets and cliques
intersect in at most one vertex so we
have these these this clique of vertices
that depend on on each particular X u
value but then if we look at the
independence polynomial its summing over
products where the products are over
independent sets so every monomial that
appears in the sum can only have a
single copy of X sub U and therefore the
whole polynomial Q is also multi linear
in X so now when we're doing the
rounding if we're increasing the
probability of a node being u then Q is
is changing linearly in our in our
perturbation of X sub u so that means
that one of those two directions is
going to make Q go up right and
therefore since our cheating version of
the Shira region just requires Q to be
positive one of those two directions is
going to preserve positivity of Q okay
so that is proof of the the local EMA
modulo the small amount of cheating okay
okay so you so you need a bit of care
there as well that relates to the
cheating so so so essentially what what
the cheating is saying what the cheating
is saying is that even if you look at
the the probability of event of small
sets of events occurring you you have
control over those so so essentially if
I choose a certain P prime value then
you essentially I want to choose the P
prime value to be supported on a single
set on onus on a you know have support
size one and and that will tell you that
each of the individual events does not
occur okay so it's a bit hard to see
because I haven't explained the cheat
but the same reason why the cheating is
justified is the same reason that
justifies that the events don't occur
okay so we can talk about that
okay all right so let's now get to the
algorithmic question so so our so I'll
state our main algorithmic results so so
so what we need to do here is we need to
you know do this coloring to preserve
feasibility and in the shear region and
and and so what we need to do is to be
able to test membership in the shear
region right we want to know which of
these two directions is going to
preserve the feasibility so the main
ingredient is is an FP toss for the
independence polynomial and our FP toss
works you know the region within which
it works is exactly the Shira region up
to this small slack parameter that we
need so our statement is so if you have
any point P such that if you blow it up
by a factor of 1 plus alpha so you have
a little bit of slack and is still in
the shear region then there's a
deterministic algorithm to compute a 1
plus epsilon approximation so NFP toss
for Q evaluated at the point P in the
following run time so basically n over
epsilon alpha to the power of log D
divided by square root alpha in the
exponent
so for you know for constant amounts of
slack then you're getting you know in
constant degree graphs then it's a
polynomial time algorithm now I hesitate
a bit to call it an FB toss because of
these you know parameters in the
exponent that you can you can think of
it as a FB toss okay so alright so why
might you be interested in such a thing
well you know so this relates to
statistical physics as we'll see on the
next slide so no so people are
interested in in computing the the roots
of this independence polynomial even for
fixed concrete graphs so for example for
the integer lattice in the plane you
know it's physicists are interested in
studying exactly the location of of the
root and you know their papers giving
you know lengthy calculations of lengthy
estimates of this root so potentially
this FP task could also be useful to
physicists but how we're going to use it
is in the following way
so we can use it as a membership tester
for the shearer region so we can give so
this is a so it now becomes a quasi
polynomial time algorithm so run time
something like n to the root n for
deciding membership in the in the shear
region and and so we end up with
something similar for the LLL so suppose
you have an L ll scenario with M
variables such that the event
probability is lie in the shear region
with slack alpha then we can give a
deterministic algorithm to construct a
point avoiding all the bad events again
in time something you've quite a sub
exponential in in the parameters and in
M so so the runtime basically you know
end to the end to the root M log D so
you know compared to previous algorithms
that you may have seen for the local EMA
you know some previous randomized
algorithms are certainly much better so
we have polynomial time algorithms
polynomial time randomized algorithms
and then there's also deterministic
algorithms under some stronger
hypotheses that that also run in in
polynomial time but I think the you know
the the interesting message here is that
the viewpoint of our algorithm is
different right so instead of doing
these random resampling x' no we're
using the the power of polynomials to to
gradually round to a solution okay so I
just have one more minute so let me talk
a little bit about the statistical
physics connection here so in in
statistical physics people are
interested in studying the independence
polynomial and and so they would define
it in the following way as this this
partition function which is essentially
you remove the alternating signs from
our definition and let's just restrict
to the the univariate case and the so
there are many connections between
between you know counting algorithms so
on the computational side algorithms for
evaluating this thing and in in the
physics world you know thresholds for
phase transitions occurring and so
there's the celebrated work of whites
and sly so whites showed that for
positive real parameters you can get an
FPS up to this certain threshold which
is meaningful in physics and then sly
result is that beyond that threshold
it's np-hard to to compute it so our our
work can be viewed in this context as
looking at what happens on the negative
axis and even in in in more
generally in the complex plane for for
canoe evaluating this partition function
so it's known that for sufficiently
negative parameters it's again np-hard
but our FP toss goes exactly up to that
point where the NP hardness kicks in and
so we can you know so we now have a
complete understanding on the real line
of we're computing this thing is np-hard
verses where you can get an FP toss okay
okay so I mean this is a little bit
confusing because it's about how you
quantify over the graphs so for any
fixed graph our fpbs can go up to this
graph specific parameter the closest
root to the origin for that particular
graph but then if you quantify overall d
regular graphs then you know potentially
you get moved in okay so okay so just
the last word so the technique here so
Weitz's technique is using the
correlation decay technique and our work
actually actually our algorithm is is
the same it's the same as Weitz's
algorithm but it but we proved a
multivariate and complex-valued
generalization of okay so
[Applause]
yes yes yes exactly exactly so if you
you can do a sort of a univariate
version and of our proof and and exactly
this D minus one to the D minus 1 over D
to the D parameter will come out as the
you know the the limit or the the the
the limit to it within which you get
this correlation decay when you imagine
if you allow yourself a lot of I see so
you didn't want to to to work in the in
the exact shear region but you wanted to
work in in a more restricted region yes
yes no okay that's a very good question
yeah so I don't have a proposed
potential function indeed it seems like
further progress in this area might you
know that might be a nice direction for
it because for us the main difficulty is
is dealing with this FB test right
that's what's making our algorithm slow
and so if you had a better potential
function then maybe you could get a
faster of
so also this friend like you dependence
on epsilon was very mild right like
those parameters yes just one over
epsilon I mean like why do you get okay
so in the ll algorithm we never
evaluated to high precision actually so
I think we're I think we only use it up
to constant take epsilon to be half I
think that's all we use in the yellow
algorithm yeah so there's two exactly
there's two parameters the epsilon and
the Alpha the epsilon we're happy to
take to be half the alpha okay so so
this is sort of the the trouble is that
our our FB tasks you know did not have
an N or an M in the exponent
but the lll algorithm does so there's
some difficulty in the reduction of how
the ll algorithm uses the f BTS that
causes the slack parameter to to get
much worse we can talk about that
website
let's think
[Applause]